Je m'appelle Punmaram
et elle c'est Areïta.
Elle est partout avec moi.
Je m'occupe d'une horde
de 250 chamelles et leur petit.
Je les ai tous vus naître,
mais ils m'ont toujours vu là.
Mes frères disent
que je suis le père des chameaux.
À la naissance, les chameaux n'ont pas assez
de force pour atteindre le puits de leur mère.
Je suis là pour ça, pour que mes chameaux
soient forts et qu'ils vivent longtemps.
J'appartiens à la grande tribu Rabari.
En persan, Rabari veut dire guide.
Mais nous ne sommes pas
des guides pour les hommes.
Nous sommes des guides pour les chameaux.
J'avais 12 ans quand j'ai quitté mon village
pour conduire cette horde avec mon père,
et aujourd'hui, c'est la plus grande
du Rajasthan et les meilleurs chameaux.
Mes frères et moi, on est connu pour ça.
Chaque année, pour prouver que nos chameaux
sont les plus endurants et les plus rapides,
un de nous 3, traverse le désert
pour aller au rassemblement des chameliers.
Il monte le chameau qu'il préfère.
En fait, depuis des années,
c'est moi qui traverse
le désert avec Areïta.
Demain, mes frères partiront au rassemblement.
Ils suivront la route
qui contourne le désert.
Moi, j'irai tout droit.
Au cœur des sables,
là où il n'y a pas de route.
Pendant mon voyage, ma horde reste ici.
Elle ne bougera pas
à cause des nouveaux-nés.
J'en ai eu 60 cette année
et il en reste à venir.
Celle-là est pour bientôt, mais
je sais qu'elle attendra mon retour.
Elles attendent toujours mon retour.
Il n'y a que des chamelles dans ma horde
et un seul chameau.
Je ne peux pas garder les jeunes mâles,
dès qu'ils ont 2 ans, ils se battent.
J'en ai 40 cette année.
Ils partiront avec mes frères.
Cette année, mes frères
ne veulent pas que je parte.
Ils disent que je suis trop vieux
pour traverser les sables.
Mais je partirai quand même.
Areïta est ma meilleure chamelle,
elle me conduira.
Jaisalmer, la porte du désert.
Après ses murs commence le Thar,
le pays des sables.
Plus d'eau...
Dans cette citadelle
vit l'homme qui n'oublie pas.
Tous les chameliers viennent l'écouter.
Ils racontent l'histoire de notre tribu.
Au début, le dieu Shiva a créé le chameau.
Puis, il a créé le 1er homme de ma tribu
pour s'occuper de ce chameau.
Le 1er chameau avait 5 pattes.
En voyant ça, le 1er homme a demandé :
"Comment le chameau pourrait-il marcher
avec une patte sous le ventre ?
Alors Shiva a pris dans sa main
la 5ᵉ patte et l'a remontée en l'air.
C'est pour ça
que les chameaux ont une bosse.
Et il a dit que nous étions là
pour prendre soin de ce chameau.
Dans le désert, il n'y a pas
de différence entre les hommes.
Dans le désert, c'est le chameau
qui fait la différence.
Areïta me portera 7 jours
à travers les dunes.
Si notre chemin est droit, nous trouverons
la cité de la Reine du désert,
et derrière elle,
le grand rassemblement.
Ici, tout bouge, tout se déplace.
D'un jour à l'autre, on ne reconnaît plus
le visage du désert.
Là où tant d'hommes se sont déjà perdus.
Mais Areïta est forte.
Elle peut tenir 5 jours sans boire,
si le vent s'arrête.
Le jour où une chamelle a un petit,
elle ne pense plus qu'à lui.
Elle devient incapable de conduire une horde.
Elle perd sa souplesse et sa fidélité.
C'est pour ça que Areïta
n'a pas eu d'enfant.
J'avais trop besoin d'elle.
Elle en fera un
l'an prochain et elle l'élèvera.
Mes frères ont raison.
Je deviens vieux,
c'est notre dernier voyage.
J'étais un enfant quand mon père
m'emmenait vivre avec sa horde.
Au début, j'étais perdu
au milieu de tous ces chameaux.
J'ai dû m'habituer à boire de l'eau saumâtre,
à dormir seul dans le froid.
Et puis mon père m'a appris
à les reconnaître,
à les compter le temps d'un regard.
À leur parler avec la gorge.
Et un jour, il m'a dit :
"L'homme vit au ras du sol.
Quand il monte un chameau, il décolle."
La cité de la Reine du désert.
Le Thar s'arrête ici.
On raconte que la peste a dévasté ses murs.
Les habitants ont accusé les rats.
Alors une femme est venue.
Elle a rassemblé les enfants morts,
et les a transformés en rats
pour leur rendre la vie.
Elle a dit qu'ils seraient ses enfants
et que toute vie doit être respectée,
même celle des rats.
L'épidémie s'est arrêtée.
Et pour la remercier,
on lui a construit un temple.
Pour notre famille, elle est devenue
la déesse du désert,
celle qui protège les enfants
contre la maladie.
Elle a dit que les hommes
et les animaux sont tous ses enfants.
C'est elle qui veille sur mes chameaux.
Le grand rassemblement !
Toutes les tribus s'y retrouvent
chaque année à la 1ʳᵉ lune d'avril.
Les chefs se réunissent,
écoutent les plaintes,
rendent justice
et partagent leur territoire.
Les familles marient leurs enfants
et aussi leurs plus beaux animaux.
Les histoires qu'on raconte
deviennent vite des légendes.
Les tribus viennent là depuis des siècles.
C'est le seul endroit où il y a
assez d'eau pour 100 000 animaux.
Sous le sable coule un grand fleuve
et il ne s'est jamais tari.
Il y a des caravaniers,
des bergers, des marchands,
toutes les races de bétail et
toutes les familles qui vivent de l'élevage.
Chaque tribu a sa réputation.
Pour ce qui est des chameaux,
c'est notre famille que l'on vient voir,
et c'est mon vieux frère qui part.
Les hommes pensent que la solitude
du désert est terrible,
mais pour moi, la vraie solitude est ici.
Je n'ai pas de vie en dehors de ma horde.
Mes frères disent
que je devrais rentrer au village.
Qu'un jour, il faut arrêter
de suivre les chameaux.
Tant que j'aurai assez de force
pour aider un chameau à venir au monde...
Je resterai là.